hey guys it's Justine and today we're
going to talk about the Apple watch
Ultra I also have a little unboxing here
so being a tech Creator sometimes people
just send you things and you don't even
know like where they came from I don't
know where this came from I'm not sure
who said this there was no note but I'm
really excited about it so it's a
titanium Apple watch Ultra band and I've
actually been really wanting one of
these and I didn't even know that they
made one and well here we go we've got
one right here that just showed up in my
mail so thank you I guess to sandmark or
whoever sent this I'm I'm hyped to check
it out so let's open it up
that oh my gosh this looks this looks so
good I mean it is a little masculine but
I'm so here for it look at that nice
this is so nice
I can't wait to wear this like I love
the chain link style they also have a
little tool here so I feel like this is
going to be a bigger project than I
thought it was going to be
I originally wanted to wear the Milanese
loop on my Apple watch band but because
you do need to wear the 45 millimeter it
was actually too big so whenever I would
wear it it would completely just like
overlap the watch because it was too
large so this is great because I'll be
able to fit it to size of whatever I
need so here's our little tool how do we
do this we've got extra pieces I should
probably save those let's put it on it's
definitely gonna be too big but I don't
feel like resizing it right now
just beautifully oh yeah this is gonna
look freaking incredible but look how
many of these I need to take out oh my
goodness that's so many here's the band
clasps just like so oh this looks so
good and it's really lightweight it
matches the titanium almost perfect
wow this looks so freaking good I can't
wait to size this I'm not gonna do it
right now because I feel like this is
more of a process that I want to get
into right now so I'm going to work on
this later so it has now officially been
I would say maybe like seven or eight
months since the Apple watch Ultra has
come out and it still to me has been I
think one of the most surprising Apple
products that has exceeded my
expectations obviously we saw how cool
it was in all of the demonstrations that
you could take it out in super low
temperatures you can use it as a dive
computer and you can take it and really
push it to its limits and yeah that's
cool but like most people aren't really
gonna put themselves in those scenarios
now when I first got this I said I was
going to get scuba certified I do
sometimes make a lot of plans and then I
never actually get around to being able
to accomplish those plans or those goals
so scuba certification was something
that like I wanted to do but deep down I
was terrified still am a little
terrified of the water because I'm not a
strong swimmer and going underwater I I
don't really I don't like the feeling of
it I start getting a little panicky and
living in California like you would
think that
um I should be quite comfortable in the
water well I'm not so recently I had
this plan that my sister and I were
going to go and get scuba certified to
test out the oceanic app on the Apple
watch so I'm planning to do a whole
video about the process of getting dive
certified and using the Apple watch
Ultra as a dive computer but when I went
to the Maldives uh not too long ago they
had a Dive Center there and I thought
okay like maybe I'll just go do like one
of their little intro Dives so I did and
all of my fears of the water were well
they were correct I was terrified first
thing that we did there was like a
little scuba exploration where you know
you kind of go in they get you
comfortable in the water and you kind of
learn the ropes of like what you're
supposed to do when you actually go for
the dive and this is very entry level so
basically anyone can do this so I
thought yeah it'll be easy let's go and
the wild thing about all of this is I
didn't even and wear my Apple watch on
this first dive because the only watch
band that I had was the trail Loop and I
was afraid that it was going to come off
in the water because it's Velcro so I
didn't even freaking wear it I didn't
even bring my Ocean band because I had
zero intention of diving I didn't even
know that was an option but once I got
there and had read that the Maldives is
one of the top destinations to dive I
felt like that was something that I
couldn't let Pass Me By in case I never
make it back there so we go out we do
this dive I'm freaking out just in the
shallow water like having to be able to
like just clear the mask if any of you
have ever Dove before you kind of know
what goes into it but as someone who
doesn't like the water and it's
terrified it was incredibly Panic
inducing but thankfully I do have very
good breath control and I'm able to calm
myself down in very high stress
situations so I used that I knew that
like you have to calm down or you're
gonna die that's basically a life or
death situation when you are underwater
so anyway I fight through through the
Brewing panic attack as we're about to
go into the water for the first time I
mean even just like falling back into
the boats terrifying I literally was
probably crying underneath of my mask so
thankfully you can't see it but I did it
and then I was like well wait a minute I
have like five more days here and it
takes four days to finish this
certification course so I decided to
just go for it I ended up getting dive
certified so I basically went from
completely terrified to oh my gosh I now
have a scuba certification and it was
honestly an incredible life-changing
experience why I'm kind of telling you
this whole story is because the Apple
watch kind of motivated me to do that
and I do feel like sometimes using Tech
to our advantage to motivate us to reach
goals to try to get in shape I owe a lot
of my fitness achievements to my gadgets
because they tell me when I'm not
sleeping enough even though my body
knows I'm not I sometimes need to see
those facts I stopped running as much as
I used to before so I can tell that my
cardio levels were obviously not where
they used to be I know my resting heart
rate is pretty low and when I'm not
running actively I can tell that starts
raising slightly so I was like all right
let's step up the cardio a little more
to bring that back down and get back
into that range that I felt was
comfortable for me so having these
devices be able to just give us that
little push that we need I think is so
awesome I was definitely very impressed
with this as a dive computer it's not
having actually gone through the course
and understanding what a dive computer
actually is I mean in theory like I
understood it but I didn't actually
understand until I was under the water
and this started blinking for the first
time telling me that I was at my safety
stop so one of the things that I
realized while I was underwater I did
have two dive computers just because you
should always have a backup no matter
what the thing that I noticed though is
the first day that I dove I had been
learning everything in meters and my
watch was in feet I didn't really know
how many feet were in a meter which is
probably something that I should have
known uh I didn't but I did have the
other Drive computer on so I was doing a
little comparing here so all that to be
said I finally understand the appeal of
the Apple watch Ultra I am obsessed with
the Apple watch Ultra way more than I
was when I first got it I'd love to hear
from you guys though what is your
biggest fear I feel like honestly water
is and was my biggest fear but I
definitely feel so much better having
kind of conquered that and knowing that
a lot of these things is Mind Over
Matter always easier said than done but
I highly recommend it and I hope that
some of you can get to experience this
incredible underwater world like I have
just scratched the surface like there's
so many places that that I can go and
dive and explore and being underwater
with these fish and these sea life it's
like an out-of-body experience because
it's like you don't belong there like
you are in their world you have to
respect and there's like this weird
unspoken understanding when you're just
kind of like eye to eye with a sea
creature they're like I see you I know
you're not supposed to be here but I
accept you and I'm gonna swim around you
it was literally it's actually
life-changing I say that about a lot of
things but this is definitely an
experience that I don't regret and I
can't wait for more experiences there's
gonna be so many cool videos that I'm
gonna be able to make underwater and not
only like this opens up a whole new
world of scuba and Diving tech oh my
gosh I can't wait if you guys are divers
please I would love to hear any advice
you have great places to dive gear that
I should check out I am so excited for
this new hobby and I'm so excited to be
a part of the community I've been
watching a ton of videos and there's so
many cool videos of people doing
incredible things diving in amazing
locations and now like getting into
underwater housing like different
cameras Oh my gosh this is we're going
down a complete other trajectory thank
you guys for watching this was supposed
to be an Apple watch video about how
I've been liking the Apple watch but I
feel like it led me to a new really cool
hobby so yeah the Apple watch Ultra I
guess you could say it changed my life
is that a clickbait title or is that
just are we are we reaching I'm not sure